what's up good humans welcome to another
episode this is the show odd men out
where your judgments are thrown out the
window
out the window make sure you stick
around to the end because we want to
gift more crew necks and we're going to
give it to the most
insightful comments for the rules at the
end the rules at the end
enjoy the episode does anyone have a
name for their genitalia
who what do you call you what do you
call yours
paris
[Music]
we brought together seven non-virgins i
am not a virgin i am not a virgin i
am not a virgin i am not a virgin i am
not a virgin
i am not a virgin i am not a virgin
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives he or she wins the
entire prize
[Music]
okay okay i say we just start asking
questions and everyone answers i agree
does anyone have a name for their
genitalia
my initial thought was sean he seemed
too
confident too talkative let's go around
the circle all right figure it out
what do you call yours harris okay
harrison okay
when did everyone lose their virginity
age that's a good one
19 12. hold on
12. yes it was on myspace what yeah it
was on my screen
we don't have time for the [ __ ] time
for the story i feel like everyone
wanted to control the situation
we weren't getting anywhere when was the
last time you guys had sex
two days ago three days last night it's
been three weeks
we got nowhere else bro what do we do
we've covered no ground
what about you wait wait no you didn't
answer the question wait i said recently
recently there's barely enough time to
introduce ourselves let alone
vote someone out
i didn't feel like she was telling the
truth or maybe she was just nervous
good luck you guys i hope you made the
right choice no
i don't think we did what nation no i
trusted you
i was shocked i definitely thought it
was going to be jonathan or
emily i don't think at first glance i
look like a virgin everyone feels
confident that you already caught the
mole
you can end the game now raise your hand
if you have
doubt and you would like to continue the
game
so when you lost your virginity how did
it how to go down
high school both virgins didn't know
what the hell we were doing what was the
first letter of her first name
jay that was quick how about you okay
i'm a late bloomer so i lost mine at 21.
where i worked at a movie theater and he
was my co-worker
so kind of scandalous what about you why
are you
her name was harmony and how'd you guys
meet
myspace myspace you next uh i was 14.
it lasted about two minutes so i was 16
16 guys to a girl named stacy stacy in
the back of my volvo
i was also a late bloomer i was i
believe i was in college
and how did you lose it like where was
it at uh in
my apartment slash dorm
it wasn't i lived very questionable i
lived off campus
so not a dorm how many people have you
slept with
oh gosh um body count time
10 it's the virgin thing not the body
count one you know
we're just trying to figure it out all
right so rough body count
i know it's three because it's not that
many between like
30 and like
70 somewhere around there what about you
my space
maybe 100 or something i don't know oh
nice nearly a hundred
i'm 25 years old i'm old man i don't
know that i buy a hundred
look at his neck right now look at this
yeah
what do you want to know you come to
this shoot with this like
over a hundred naming his genitals
because he was playing the game so hard
i was like maybe he like really did come
to win
to the point of giving himself a fake
hickey okay
oh yeah he's in a relationship oh who's
in a relationship
how long have you been together a few
months okay how long is a few months
like
six months no less yeah he's gone he's
gone
i'm gone oh you do think it's me i just
like figured to
maybe get rid of the guy with the pony
t-shirt
oh no it's like 100 percent like
it's so obvious that it's like yo is it
if it's obvious we have to
we have to take it i think so honestly
though i'm
kind of flattered i didn't want to be
too defensive about like no i'm not
i'm not a virgin just because i'm kind
of like it's okay if you are what's the
craziest place you guys have had sex
um i want to say like in an elevator
yeah
like a obstacle course on my college
campus
like one of those rope course things
maybe you went from zero to a hundred
dollars
uh the bed the bed that's a great one
leaning with you never went outside the
bed
maybe one day guys guys that could be
like your sleeper in the dark
it's kind of like a hive mentality you
just want to be safe
and do whatever it takes
[Music]
oh man good luck guys
i had a different shirt i was told that
this shirt worked fine
i feel like that may have contributed
but also
maybe don't judge people by the shirts
that they choose to wear
what's everyone's favorite aspect of sex
what do you guys like the most about sex
um i like the foreplay that's the real
at the end of the day it's a real answer
is it the four player yeah the fourth
play is the real answer the ending's a
real answer i see the intimacy the
middle
oh you're a lover so i mean that's how
hey you know that's sweet bro
it's like not the destination for you
it's the journey exactly
the intimacy yeah with someone you love
and that's who you trust and
who i would want to have sex with and
how long have you been with your current
boyfriend uh six months
how long were you single before that oh
i had another boyfriend from the movie
theater
but we broke up that was the movie and
then i had a one-night stand
so that was the three foundations yes
okay i mean that's actually believable
yeah i mean that's just when she
referenced like
but like statistically if we eliminated
her we'd make more money
i was kind of just playing game theory
at that point i've been the most
transparent here just saying we've all
been transparent after all
come on i'd rather be in a relationship
than just have sex with
anyone good for you but that changed my
[Music]
in the back of my mind i was
stereotyping them by the way that they
dressed and acted
[Music]
i kind of just de facto got everybody to
kick out all the introverted people
because i thought it was a good game
plan but maybe i was kind of messed up
the ball is still there good luck emily
you're sewing discontent in the group
okay okay yeah oh i think they're
teaming up no
i want to ask you more questions and i
want to ask you more questions yeah yeah
jolie
she like winked and then forgot to open
her eye back up
i think so like yeah listen to three and
then you said three in the last two
weeks but so i went to palm springs two
weeks ago
and then two days ago i had sex with
someone sean and i did team up we just
kind of like looked at each other and
we're just like
okay we kind of knew that we were safe i
think he
could potentially still be the mole all
right so ask questions
were you religious too before you had
sex yeah so if i called jerome right now
and i was like he's had sex a few times
she probably already thinks i do i mean
i've never told her i've had sex you
know what i mean it says you were 19
when you lost
no 16. 16. okay yeah back of the volvo
what color was the volvo by the way it
was gold it's like
you mean like yellow like tannish as far
as volvo did you have like padding in
there or was it just like
oh you were hurt just to see it wasn't
the greatest experience
yeah what was the was the body part that
hurt most after you finished
it was definitely my knee because it was
on like the little
the little buckle
it was bad business man i'm a big guy
yeah no okay that's all correct where
was your first time
where yeah it was in a bed in the guy's
house that we're at and his parents were
gone
did you say 30 to 70 18 yeah yep
the math seems all i think if you said
like okay 15
yeah but that's the truth that's up
there especially like for an 18 year old
i'm not here to judge anybody or
anything like that but
she could be coming in here trying to be
like i'm the coolest
she's saying a big number she's young
therefore i believe it because if she
was coming in here as the mole she'd be
like oh like maybe like 10.
i think she's safe and that vulnerable
story about your knees
that that makes sense we haven't asked
you in a while i'm a sex symbol
okay well all right he's getting there
we got us all in
25 how do you 27. 18 with 30.
i don't know like i'm gonna i like
nothing
i needed to like sway one of them so i
was thinking like trevor was the mole
okay we'll just go with emmanuel for now
but he wasn't budging
i don't think he has a beard with like
earrings and a tattoo and
a virgin i don't think he didn't throw
me in the fire it's kind of like you
know what you're cool you know throwing
me in me and emanuel started kind of
indirectly teaming up too like
telepathically you think sean
he brought the the hickey was probably
like a bottle cap he just put on his
neck
oh that's a bottle cap tell me that's a
bottle cap right now
i realize you know it's kind of hard to
recreate that so i thought it was real
but i thought it was a little scripted
i know it's not you i'm not even gonna
question that
yeah i those numbers bro i'm sorry
it's not i know for a fact
honestly i knew that sean had my back no
matter what it would have been
2v2
there's been a tie in the event of a tie
we do a re-vote
the two people who have tied are jolie
and trevor
[Music]
do you trust me
that's gonna be the same it was obvious
that shawn and jolie were gonna vote
trevor off and then try and get
me off there's another tie
can we just say that we're done and yeah
can we just say we're done
yeah i think the mold is probably out
but i was just trying to make more money
so
raise your hand if you want to end the
game uh let's just end it
i love all you guys if the light turns
green you voted the liar out if the leg
turns red
the goal is still in the game and you
lose
what it was was it you was him
it was you you stinky boy
oh my i'm sorry trevor
most people don't expect me to be a
virgin and unless ass
i don't say anything i get it it's the
game survival of the fittest so i i
understand i think he's a sociopath
hey don't judge a book by its cover you
really never know
so i'm still a virgin because i'm
waiting for marriage i grew up in a
church
sex is a covenant between me god and my
future wife
i just made that promise to myself and
my family and to god that i would wait
until marriage
oh that's a lot of whoa it's a lot of
cash
can you can i help you get that money my
walk of shame oh yeah
my money walk of shame bring money it
smells it smells like this i'm just
gonna
like paper wow group hug come on
yo what's up good humans thanks for
watching before you comment on episode
ideas we have an even better idea of
what you can comment below that's right
we want a gift
crew next to you but what we're going to
do is we're going to be reading through
all the comments and we're going to
choose our three
most favorite mind-blowing insightful
mind-blowing comments we're going to
choose them
and we'll gift you a crew neck as always
like subscribe and we'll see you next
time